welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name's Hisham azuz today I'm
really excited to be joined by John
Gorgan he's a CEO of finis James you are
a specialist tech sales recruitment
business have offices in Manchester
London San Francisco New York they
currently have circled 45 people in the
business currently have been going for
17 years in July and
min-jeong of sat down previously John's
also participated in a live podcast
webinar during this period as well but
what we're gonna do today is gonna be a
bit bit different I think Jon Moxley you
thought would be a good idea with so
many recruitment business owners
recruiters thinking about what is work
gonna be like after this and how
flexible is it gonna be I'm not going to
be in the office five days a week like
what does actually return into work look
like and I know that you've had some
interest in experiences in the past with
things that you've implemented of your
business that I think you felt that you
were really inclined to sort of share
and sort of talk about how you're
thinking about things and the
conversations you're having and so we're
gonna have a sort of dedicated
conversation we've got a bit of an
agenda around a guess the future of
returning to work returning to a
recruitment business right I think I
think you did talk a bit about this when
we we sat down the wall ago but I think
what we wanted to start with is project
freedom and what that project was to you
in your business and let's just just
start there and fill everyone in on sort
of what that project was all about ok
yes a project freedom was an experiment
that we ran two years ago now so myself
and Sarah my wife and business partner
and James May our MD we sat down we
basically said let's just break
everything off and secretly experiment
on working in a slightly different way
so we'd all worked in recruit while
certainly myself and James and worthy
movement I was 25
I am James was 10 to 12 years in and we
kind of said look is there a way of
doing things where we can be more
productive more efficient and have more
fun and you know create more revenue and
make more profit and we kind of looked
at two or three things we could do and
then we settled on what we termed
project freedom so we started with
wanting so it was our amia team and we
basically sat down with those five
people and we said a lot moving forward
for the next six weeks you guys can work
where you want when you want and the
only thing we are physically interested
in is the results so it's the interviews
the revenue the deals the profit does
the only thing we want to talk are the
only outcomes it all outcome based all
results based and so we basically said
if you want to spend some time in the
office you can do that if you want to
spend time at the beach you can do that
if you can if you want to you know work
a couple of hours in the morning and
some hours in the evening and basically
spend the day on the golf course that is
absolutely fine with we're only
interested in in there was Dalton what
was interesting in for the six week
period what we found was that the
performance levels of that particular
team increased and one of the main
takeaways was the the quality of the
interviews they were setting up increase
so whereas in the past people would be
you know inclined to maybe settle per an
interview for a at 35 40 K level handed
her what was happening is they were
basically going further up the food
chain and setting up interviews that
would ultimately bring bigger fees so
the the interviews were getting settled
for 60 60 K base level candidates or 70
or 80 so they tended to get the same
number of interviews as they were doing
pre experiment well the the quality of
the interviews and the value of the
deals that would come in on the back of
that was increased
so that the quality of the what you they
were taking things more seriously in
terms of what am I trying to achieve
what am I trying to do as opposed to
getting another interview on the board
yeah because there were the only things
it was outcome based right there are the
only things that was there Northstar was
aiming for yeah correct and what we
looked out in the past you know you you
know we include that something a few
years previous where you know you'd
sometimes see something you know I've
arranged six interviews this way and
they might be super junior opportunities
on not so great fees and even if you did
get you know they you know it wouldn't
really kind of you know move the dial
and get you where you wanted to be
whereas it was a bit like you know
getting that number on the board isn't
as important is the profits the revenues
for the the out courts it's the it's the
endgame they're thinking about so they
became that bit more organized and not
been more disciplined and I remember at
the time you know a couple of the girls
who were within that program they were
basically doing a gym class together at
six o'clock in the morning about five
o'clock in the morning doing a gym class
being super energized and then cracking
on through the word and then they'd have
like all evening to chill out and relax
and socialize etc etc so you know their
mental health improve their productivity
improve their efficiency improvement it
got to a stage when we then did we
looked at the results and we kind of
thought right we're going to roll this
out across the whole business okay
that's where it went a little bit wrong
because I think that I think cuz that's
what what you said is that's what people
gonna be thinking about now right so
what are we gonna be rolling out of
course the business I think this is what
so that's great context and yeah that's
really interesting
so yeah please do share Howard then when
when you started to get more people
involved I think because when we thought
we've got a team do it and it's worked
really well we kind of thought what we
don't want to do is pick and choose who
we give this yeah because that would
have seemed kind of maybe other time it
seemed unfair and it was these guys were
so positive about their expense
and they were coming into the office
Danny up shot and glowing and buzzing
and super successful and this is amazing
that could have been a bit of jealousy
if for the video definite Judaism so
what we basically said was right you
know this is this is the same for
everybody now where were we got things a
little bit wrong is people who had been
in the business three four five six
months it would may be graduating from
University you know 12 months earlier
they weren't ready amount of freedom and
that amount of flexibility and everybody
had you know a plant you know yeah you
know I'm gonna start work a little bit
later but I'm gonna work into the
evenings and that was great you know on
paper what do you practice it was you
know you start a bit a little bit later
and you finish on time and then you
don't catch up on the work you didn't do
and you know people would say yeah you
know I'm going to pop into the office on
the Tuesday but then it's suddenly
raining in that meet up but you know we
were having people can of ringing as up
channel yeah I'm going to be calling in
later and I'm going to be doing there
something white hours yeah they couldn't
understand the whole kind of flexible
nature of things so people were like
reporting in and you know I just want to
tell you what else fell by they had to
let you know that they're working yeah
an excite will we don't need that and
you know what we're interested in is
what you've achieved on a Friday so the
way we played it we said look you've got
to be another Monday morning to get you
kind of morning meeting still on and
your plan and your strategy and you've
got to be in Friday afternoon between
those times you know you do what you've
won and where you want to do it and if
you want to work in a cost or establish
that's cool too but what was happening
man is people would get him through the
work and it tended to be the more junior
people yeah and they weren't getting
through the work and they were then kind
of coming up with excuses and yeah you
know I would have done that thought this
happened and that happened and it was
basically in many ways because they
couldn't be trusted but as far as my I'm
concerned it's a bit like you know when
you go from school and
College yeah to university you know
people made that transition and then
suddenly very often there's not a
register yeah now yeah you're right it's
a good comparison so there's no register
you know there's no kind of roll call
you know there's no kind of you know
checking in and doing this and that and
what you find is some people go into
that environment and unique and
absolutely excel and they look at the
freedom and they love the flexibility
and they love the idea of managing their
own time all the people don't go into
any lectures bail out after three months
and it was just too much for them so I
think what we realize is that you know
if we were to do run the project again
and you know I think there's good chance
we will we would put certain parameters
in place and you know for certain people
who got to a certain grade in the
business maybe they can have been
reordered the flexibility yeah and the
trust but if you haven't got to a
certain point in your career
whereby you can physically do these make
myth metrics you know in a normal
environment then that was the difficulty
you know people who had struggled maybe
to do for interviews a week in normal
conditions asking them to do it working
from home without a manager on tap or a
director on tap that kind of answer
questions was probably too big an act so
we put too much trust too much
responsibility into inexperienced people
and how long was that period John yeah
so we run that for another eight weeks
eight weeks okay and the interesting
thing is you know we didn't we didn't
lose money you know we didn't kind of
have a massive impact in a positive way
or a negative way however we were
getting people come back to us saying
and we gradually showed more people
spending more time in the office in the
office and we haven't even like met
managers saying look you know I kind of
you know if you would have told me kind
of three months ago I was going to get
this opportunity I would have thought it
was actually amazing it's not as good in
practice as it sounds on paper and I
think it'll be the same now you know
the people have been working from home
for three months who for working from
home was not working from home as the
Holy Grail
and now kind of thinking you know well
you know it's been fine and I've done
okay
but getting into the office two three
days a week
sounds you know or better as a plan come
in and to be like to yourself you know
you've been you know working from home
for the last couple of months and then
suddenly I've seen something that you
seem to be more energized or more
positive and yeah more enjoying life the
fact you're actually getting into your
office in London now on a yeah I think I
think yeah I think yeah I think all I'd
probably add the caveat to that John I'd
say is that and a few people have said
this to me and it's completely right is
that working from home now isn't working
from home like before this to go I mean
I think I think that's a real important
factor to highlight isn't it that and
that's why I think that's what's gonna
that's gonna be the interesting part as
things change and as students get to
quote-unquote back to normal I think and
what does the actual future of a normal
typical recruitment recruits a week look
like I guess just to run that off then
John what would the I guess they're just
to wrap up what were the key learnings
end of that sort of initial four to six
week period of the initial team and then
they're eight weeks of every one what
were the Keelung so clearly it was about
actually and people that maybe haven't
had as much experience found it way more
difficult but what were the key
learnings and from project freedom I
think the key learnings and then so if
you look at the kind of the initial
pilot experiment with five or six people
yeah and I'm doing it on mass what we
found in in many respects is the the
pilot that we did was done with more
experienced more mature more recruitment
savvy individuals yeah so in hindsight
you know because they wanted it to work
it was always gonna work yeah and so you
know our learnings for
if we were to go for a similar
experiment again to look at how kind of
a blended team where you've got an
experienced person with a rookie with a
junior and have you know our team our
immediate team at the time but one of
our strongest teams and so in hindsight
we could have used a kind of an average
team with a better collection of people
but I think our biggest kind of
learnings from it was that people need
to understand you know you can't assume
that every individual is like you yeah
they totally get what an outcome-based
cam scenario looks like so I thought it
was pretty clear that look you know if
the goal when the objective is to
register for candidates arrange for
interviews and get you know a deal to
two deals a month for me if I would have
been told about 25 years ago when I got
into recruitment I would have thought
that's pretty easy that's pretty basic
right I know what I need to do I will
crack off for some people there wasn't
the straight edges and the clarity that
they made they really understood that so
what we didn't put in place was you know
what they were responsible for mm-hmm
and what the the can of the metrics
would look like to support for
interviews yeah that makes sense yeah so
what we didn't put it you know we didn't
want you know strict kpi's but what we
could have put in place would be more
kind of the expectation is you will
spend X hours doing this and you will
make that many calls and you will do
this many LinkedIn updates and you will
live so I think what we didn't put in
place is you know what are our what
you're responsible for is individual and
what are the repercussions if you don't
do that hmm so we had guys not doing it
week one and not doing it week two and
we haven't really empowered our billing
managers to basically say right what are
you gonna do when they don't do it so we
were having the radical candor and the
difficult conversations and just so what
we've laid this out this is what you
need to do why aren't you doing it
what help do you need what support you
need so we have people come failing and
instead of them thinking right I've got
to so if it was if it was me I would
have thought right okay well I'm not
gonna numbers I need to work some extra
hours now to get to my for interviews
they were just thinking well if the
Friday you know I'm not doing anything
but you know mañana mañana mañana you
know let's give it a go again next week
so yeah no I think it's are you gonna
say something else yeah I was gonna say
you know what you need the repercussions
in place or what happens if you don't do
it so if you're gonna go results
orientated like for example you know if
I give you you know the analogy of a
football team you know football's back
on Wednesday I think that man United
something to that but what's interesting
is let's say you've got a hard time and
you've had a bit of a sinker your
manager sends you out and he basically
said look you've got 15 minutes to nail
this or you're gonna get hold off you
know where you stand and you know you
willing to do it or or you'll be
substituted at the 60 minute mark and I
think if you've got quite inexperienced
building managers and it was new to them
as well we haven't really explained on
because the proper pilot had worked so
well we just assumed that everybody's
going to be really into this and
everybody's going to kind of make it
work what we didn't realize was that the
communication between insulting billing
manager billing manager director / owner
wasn't as connected as it needed to be
to get a program like this up and
running
yeah I think that that's really
interesting John I think it's exactly
that hasn't it's clearly I think you
hear a lot people sort of saying online
about sort of like we need to be more
outcome-based more results orientated
don't need to hit people with the KPI
stick but I think it's what you just
said it's like yeah we need to know what
success looks like but and then actually
what would have really helped our guys
and will help people is just saying so
this is these are the results that you
need
but just to give you an idea of
typically what someone has done in the
past to get them now
achieve that is mysticism this and then
the final bit which you've just said is
then and by the way these are the sort
of minimum standards that we require as
I said this is outcome with John you
this is saw the ultimate goal however we
know that typically the formula to help
you achieve that is these types of
numbers and the minimum standard is this
unless you're communicating with me
saying hey John
I'm not having called as many people
whatever but actually this is what's to
go I'm in so I think it's what you said
right it's actually there's got to be
some sort of goals or expectations in
place so by the way this is the formula
to get those outcomes that you can aim
for you don't have to get it exactly but
typically this is what you're looking at
and what to expect and then from a
management perspective it's then like
okay well by the way this is the line
where this is the minimum standard of
output or effort or whatever it is that
you're measuring that we need from you
and okay that that's really interested
in so I guess with with this with this
sort of insight and and what we're
talking about like what's your mindset
towards return to work and the sort of
future of the philly james workplace and
and and and today because i think it's
going to be different right so so I've
been to her office you've got quite a
bit of space which I'm sure helps with
sort of making the your workplace safe
but what was your mindset towards
bringing people back to work what are
you thinking about yeah so I mean we've
been having discussions over the last
couple of weeks on it and what we want
to do is we've got let's say out of 45
people we've got 30 people on Bill okay
what we wanted to do was make sure that
everybody's communicated with
effectively and everybody knows where
they stand so what was good now is
everybody knows what date they return to
the business and god that helps I'll
tell you that much so we've got some
people coming back to you I one some
people coming back all this one some
people coming back September 1 but they
know what the positive what we've got
then is a combination of some people are
going to be
back in July full-time to complement the
people we've still got on the pitch now
some people are coming back three days a
week and I put something out on LinkedIn
yesterday you know how you get a manage
three days a week I'm really intrigued
as to whether you know some people it
may well favor a Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday all the people may well fade
but you know an old day Monday for five
days you know Tuesday Wednesday Thursday
Friday morning so we're going to
basically look at the spoke solution for
everybody and kind of what suit the
individual based on their circumstances
now we imagine that if somebody for
example up in Manchester is working
three days and they're working Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday that is two of those
days of the three will be in the office
one will be from home now if for example
people in London don't wanna jump on a
two and their work in three days or the
work in five half days the likelihood at
the moment is they'll do that from home
so what we're looking at hm is a spoke
solution but each and every person
within the business that we can support
and so if they want to be in the office
T can be in the office if you want to
work for Dominic from home you can work
predominately from home but what we are
in our main make sure we do is get those
tangibles in place whereby you know if
you are working three days away you know
we need these little expectations now
these are the expectations in terms of
Camden's registered new job specs taken
you know if you're a 180 new client
based individual interviews arranged
because what we found in the last three
months is our numbers in terms of you
know introduced arranged per person the
people who are still on the pitch have
actually increased okay
so what we found is you know the ability
to arrange interviews hasn't been
diminished but in Coleman so yes there's
less jobs but the jobs that we have got
are as committed if not more committed
than the ones we have pre coded so you
know people want you might have met with
in our business your people like
Rhian assassins has actually arranged
more interviews on a weekly basis over
the last three months than she was doing
pretty coldly and she's working from
home and not having to travel into
London from Hamel every day and things
like that so you know weird get
basically seeing it get done during
kool-aid and so we don't anticipate
individuals coming back in three days
awake it's not gonna be a case where but
if they're not arranging interviews
we're gonna have a problem yeah okay and
then just quickly sorry maybe I didn't
understand this right but the free day
so is that you talking about plots on
furlough there yeah yeah okay so what we
want to do is still manage our overhead
yeah and so you know if we manage to
let's say reduce our overhead by 50% you
know over the last three months you know
we've got a number now that's more
achievable and doable but it would have
been pre-code so our philosophy is you
know that overhead will increase to some
extent in July it will further increase
in August it will further increase in
September we try make incremental it
will be incremental and you know we're
managing that workflow and you know even
like we've had people come back into the
business
who will work in full time at the moment
who may well only be working two and a
half three days a week in in July and we
will play it by by the week you know if
somebody has you know a real tough way
and they're really struggling and then
you know the following week that'd be
more comfortable only working two or
three days we'll we'll play that by ear
and it's managing the overhead and
managing the capacity yeah so very
simply them for people listening because
a lot of people might be getting this
communicated to them or thinking about
this is so basically very simply is you
so the the sort of next part of this
scheme is that you can bring people back
on part-time to do pots on hours that
you pay for right that you pay out over
the business and then the other part
there to top up to that that for them to
get their full-time wage would be then
compensated by the government yes so the
work the way we see it I'm talk about
I've got this right you're Barisan if I
haven't is
that if somebody for example is working
three days a week
then our understanding is that they'll
get the 80 percent for the from the
government for the two days and now
they'll get the hundred percent from
village ends for the three day so they
will end up with 92 percent of their
normal yeah yeah and then you know if
you're working two days at the ACA that
was four days now you say so that's our
reading of it but what we're hopefully
what would have to be considered is that
if you've been on furlough since let's
say April 1 and you've done April May
June July and you come back August the
transition from going from doing no work
- oh my god you know is gonna be
horrendous
it's a bit like you know when you leave
uni and you get your first gig on your
first we're privileged oh you're
absolutely a four you're exhausted yeah
so you know you were in recruiting we'll
do the same thing it's like oh my gosh
there is so much to take on all you do
is sleep and recruit so we think for
those guys you know getting them in
three days so then gradually you can
only help up here is the way but I think
the key thing even now you know we've
got some of our top villas who want
burrow because you know they weren't in
the right kind of mental went to be
cracking on with work at the month so we
wanted to support everybody's mental
health and the ones that we have on the
pitch wanna be on the pitch yeah and all
of the cracking on and want to be
working and the ones who want to still
be on third our own perfect so we
acknowledge that there's a lot of talk
and a lot of noise on LinkedIn about you
know people who were on furlough and
didn't want to be on Burrell and people
who are in work you don't want to be in
work we're going to add that you know we
basically have a balance whereby the
guys you want to be on the picture on
the pitch the guys who don't want to be
on the pitch now or don't want to be on
the pitch full-time come July won't be
on the pitch full-time yeah okay so what
does can just get your thoughts on John
said we're talking about because this is
where I think a lot of people
would think about related they might
they might know that come July that
they're gonna be working three days a
week etc so just quickly like how much
you know you said that around the sort
of bespoke John you're back three days a
week and and and if you tell me like I
guess what I want to know from you is
like how much of it have you pull it in
like the ball in their Court if you go I
mean like I have it has it really been
led by hey John look like you told us
that you can't come back free that we've
agreed it's three days a week you that's
what you've communicated and then have
you said how do you want to do it yeah
totally America because what I realize
is having somebody do something they
don't want to do it's a waste of time it
doesn't work I've got twenty year old
children who were a second year on uni
and if they don't want to do something
they don't do it yeah and I waste a lot
of energy and a lot of time trying to
encourage them to do things they don't
want to it and it's waste my time so
what I realize is that if you put the
ball in the individuals core then
they're empowered they're in control and
you know they take responsibility for
their career and their job and their
diary and their time and so what I'm
hoping is that if somebody's only
working three days a week you know they
really then kick hard at that and it may
well be they're working on Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday you can I'm great
weekend they can have a great Friday
great but but when they're on they're on
and they basically have to make the
absolute maximum out of those three days
but that's what that individual wants to
do but I think if I look at for example
my guys in America you know gals in San
Francisco works you know at the moment
he's in lockdown on his own and he's the
only guy in San Francisco come on now
his time difference he's eight hours
after me so he could the air all about
getting takeaway biz ever every every
afternoon and I wouldn't know because
you know I'm
you know you trust got to get on with
the work because he's building a
business out there the same way Nikki in
New York you know I don't run around you
know and I need to do three zoom calls a
day with you guys so I can see that
you're actually inside I'm not out on a
bike ride with you men see it's all on
trust but I think the more trust you
give people to come up with a plan and
then giving them the parameters which
maybe we want so strong on two years ago
you know making it their plan you know
and then they can build their way around
that and what they're looking to do and
why they're looking to do I think works
a lot better than or saying look you
know you're at this level so we want you
working five days a week we want you in
Manchester on a wood Monday or NCM
Friday people push back on that yeah you
know James ed you know I so just some so
on the obvious which is one of the sort
of key learnings then so why don't you
just talk a bit about that free day we
know those three days like what are the
expectations and so what firstly it's of
what the outcome so I think I think and
Rhiannon said this on the live podcast
webinar which I thought was great was
sort of the goals and outcomes that
she's aiming for the things that she can
control yeah right so which I absolutely
love that which is booking an interview
which is registering candidates but all
right so I guess what it'd be good to
just if you were to just break down sort
of the outcomes that you've set out for
someone work in three days and then also
then this sort of as you ascend the
boundaries and the expectations
yeah I would say I mean this is a work
in progress we're getting almost of
place you know pre July 1 and James May
RMD you know he live you know input on
this as well sorry so I will envisage
that somebody's working three days then
we would be looking at them arranging a
minimum of two interviews a week we
would be looking at them registering a
minimum of a candidate a day that you
know they're looking to take to market
so we would imagine based on our account
for five days stats and bringing them
you know rating them in a little bit
that if somebody will
registering three candidates setting up
two interviews getting you know at least
one of those two a latter stage and the
book process we would also then look at
the social side so are they basically
promising you a minimum you know three
updates a week on only are they writing
and getting out and out and you're
pushing down on it so there would be
metrics around not so much call time and
not so much about call numbers but
controlling the controllables are you
know you can control registry three
cameras so if I said to to you Monsieur
Minh you moved on recruitment for a few
years basically said right I'll tell you
what I'll give you a ground next week if
you register three candidates I'll
imagine you probably do it yeah you back
yourself to do that yeah so you know
you're buying them from somewhere and
you know the candidates candidates are
out there along with you know these
difficult situations so you know the
ones that you you shouldn't be failing
on is registering candidates you can't
always control how many of those
candidates get interviews but over a
monthly basis if somebody was working
three days a week
well that's fall days half days however
they're gonna craft it we would
anticipate a minimum of twelve
registrations and eight interviews
confirmed in an arranged and then a
number of you know interactions on
social so that they're not just liking
and sharing what they're actually coming
up with some you know date your item
posts or something interesting about
their market their industry themselves
something hmm
and then the day and then those things
are talking about their their there are
they then the minimum expectations then
like there's sort of boundaries of light
this is what we expect when you're
working this if you're not achieving
these things and let's have a
conversation as to why and if there's
anything that we just talked about yeah
I mean even if I think back to you know
the start of the whole coma thing you
know we had some people on the page
who yeah you know I want to work I want
to do this and yeah I want to crack on
who didn't meet those expectations in
April
and so we then have conversation just
say right okay so you didn't do it April
you know how confident are you of
achieving that in May and if the answer
was no not so much
then it may be an idea to take some time
to kind of reflect and kind of take some
time out and maybe do some therapy but
you know people if people would have
come to us and said no no I know I
didn't do but I will do that and I will
achieve a new one they would have said
on the pitch some of them didn't and
they're on furlough and you know they've
come back since all they're coming back
in July so those are the kind of minimum
expectations and to be fair I've been
very open and upfront and I basically
said look as you come back in or
furlough everybody within Villa Jones is
going to get a chance to prove
themselves whether you've been in the
business two months or ten years but in
the new world as we get back if you
can't arrange interviews and if you
can't actually do the minimum standards
it's unlikely they will be a family
James future all you families I've been
very open and you know we've done town
halls having that conversation so I
don't want anybody to come back in
August not arrange an interview and not
be prepared for a difficult conversation
yeah I think I think what I love about
that John and I think I think is really
evident of sort of what you do online
you you you've been very open with sort
of web how your business is doing stuff
like that which i think is amazing by
the way and I think what was great about
that is that I think there'll be huge
huge amounts of people on furlough right
now that are really uncertain or the
future of their job yeah right and I
think what I love about that is that
you're communicating the look guys these
are the minimum standards which by the
way you're in control of and so when you
do come back on the pitch these are the
expectations that again you are in
control of and if we're not hitting
these sort of things there there's going
to be a potential difficult conversation
and you're letting people know but I
think what I love about that is one
you're communicating it and two it's in
their hands do you not I mean which I
watch I think it's the most important
and also empowering to know and that
again as you said people to survive this
and the crews of the future have to be
responsible there has to be accountable
for what they need to do to hit the
outcomes that they need to but I do
think there's a bit of a disconnect
there he's showing that if I look at you
know there's you know millions of people
haven't felt on furlough I do think
there's certain people who because their
financial position hasn't deteriorated
too badly you know they basically won't
be going on holiday the about the
holiday money back they're meant to be
going to festivals divide the first of
all money back they were gonna be buying
clothes holiday you know going on the
holiday suddenly you know it got more
cat so my concern for the market a
little bit and I think we've got to be
all aware of this is that I think some
people think they're going to go back in
to my business or any other recruitment
business August 1 September 1 and crack
on as normal if they don't walk their
game and cannon basically work that bit
hard and that bit smarter and that bit
more organizing disciplined then they're
gonna be at work and that's across the
board and whether people are mentally
preparing themselves for all this one
September 1 I'm not so sure another
story here yeah so I think you know if
there's training out there is a
government opportunities people need to
be taking that because some what what I
see is coming back in August 1 July or
whatever I see the you know the playing
field
absolutely leveled so all those guys
about 20-30 vacancies I'm going any mmm
the best time from scratch and they
mentally prepared for that maybe not and
the guys who were earning the 6800 K
because they had a great client book but
they not have anymore
and they've prepared to be earning half
as much for doing the same work probably
not so I think you know business
sellner's because you know there they've
been in it living it eating and
breathing it for the last kind of three
months they've adopted and they've
changed and they've you know with I
class family James now you know close to
our 17th birthday as a star and that
that's what that's what I'm running at
the moment I'm comfortable with it James
terribly employed with it but can the
individuals who've not been in the eye
of the storm
make that transition to the whole things
changed or are they going to feel sorry
for themselves and be living in the past
and you know I used to be a contender
and that that's where it's gonna be
tricky and I see a lot of people maybe
on the bigger basics who get overtaken
by the you know the hungry people who
love the idea that it's back to back to
the start you know nobody's got a head
start you know nobody's can have you
know 20 paces ahead of them because
they've got four or five times it's kind
of you know let's go and let's let's see
who's got the energy and the hustle to
outwork sometimes the more experienced
people yeah I think it's gonna be
interesting for sure I think I did show
the post about this today cuz I think I
think is definitely difficult I think
you definitely can't paint everyone with
the same brush we were on furlough
because I mean what my girlfriend's been
on she's an office manager for a
management consultancy and she's been on
furlough from the very beginning and I
think I'm sure you've heard they're just
the remark of our I'd love to be on
furlough be like being on holiday you
get paid to do it right and I just
couldn't disagree with that more and
personally just from my own perspective
of my girlfriend being an absolute
emotional roller coaster and I think
there's gonna be a balance there John
where yes you do need to you do need to
keep your head in the game and and
prepare sort of yourself as best as you
can for what's to come and at the same
time there's also getting through the
days on furlough which is also a
challenge you know I mean so
I think yeah I think and I think you've
got there's just a bit of a balance
there and I think I do amplifies of
anyone there if they've been on further
I've been on the bench for that long
there they will be lacking a lot of
motivation by this point
and finally difficult and I think yeah
but and then there's at the same time if
you are getting coming back on the pitch
then you've got to try and give yourself
the best possible chance of
understanding what to expect and be
prepared for it otherwise it could be in
an even difficult position where you
might not have a job you know I'm on the
pitch Sarris kind of on the bench at the
moment and so no we and even even my
children you know excite you know what's
it like to be on you know Sarah's kept
busy and kind of you know got through
once yourself and she's now looking so
prepare for people coming back into the
business in July but we're aware that
every individual is different but and I
did a post something on Facebook about
what I said was you know if you are on
third oh yeah enjoy the time use the
time you know look to develop look to do
stuff you've never done before but
whatever you do don't waste it mmm
because I think the mental health aspect
of getting to the end of furlough and
you don't throw up on ones and you've
done nothing and you just wallow in
self-pity in bed every day even that's
not good so what I can tell is even if
you chose an hour or a day yeah to learn
read you know improve you know I found
myself doing that so you know and I
think you know I've already put it on
LinkedIn but you know stuff that you've
been doing I must have watched you know
2013 podcast between you know yourself
Sean yeah and alter CRN's still and you
know I'm getting my strategy and I'm
learning and I'm developing from the
stuff I learn from listening to you
interview other people and you know
that's important for me but you know
that's also an option or yeah I don't
furlough that I think you know sometimes
I think there might be a little bit you
know is it you know is it cool not to
engage
and yeah I saw a post yesterday from
somebody saying you know clients and
companies aren't engaging with work
awesome if that's case that's really bad
and that's poor form and we are doing
that but it good it's not beyond the
realms of possibility that if you're a
recruiter and you've been on board two
or three months it might be worth
putting a call into your enemy or your
CEO or your Sales Director and say look
you know I'm coming back in August you
know what can i stuff could a bit should
let me do it out John or Jamie that's a
great thing to do great internet you
know what what I've seen is you know I
can spot the guys who are going to come
back and hit it hard day one from what I
see on LinkedIn and I can spots what the
guys who and maybe going to be slower to
get back up to suite and so you've got
to take responsibility for yourself so I
think it's a bit like you know kids kids
going to uni or you don't think about
that first day in a new job you know you
see the guys you know they bought the
pencil case you know they think they've
got the books you know the one behind
everything the back and the books are
back they're ready to go and you see the
other guys who can look like they need
another week up you know I think you
know people need to set you know the
responsibilities on the companies to
engage and communicate but if you're not
being communicated to pick the phone up
yeah
magic initiatives yeah get a zoom
calling in the diary with you box and
say right okay well I know you're busy
when can we work when can we talk to
thrash out a plan so I'm ahead of the
game
getting day one yeah and so look but as
we come to the end of this just just a
couple of things
just before we finished John and so the
first thing that I'm just interests
you're talking a bit about it they're
like water salt and then it'll be like a
case-by-case basis but sort of how
what's the sort of time frame I'm trying
to sort of Oishi around if I'm coming
about three days a week
and there is gonna be an element of like
working out what's working for me what
is it like I don't know have you put
things in place whereas like look on a
weekly basis we'll say how are you
finding difficult was it I guess how
long you get roughly gonna give people
to sort of work out if they should be on
the pitch to go I mean because I think
that's that's going to be difficult so I
guess is there a sort of buffer period
there or you making sure that everyone
knows that they need to communicate what
they're finding hard what's working for
them what is it to help you understand
if they should be staying on the pitch
besides the minimum expectations and
stuff at that for me a lot of it is
mindset and you know my whole philosophy
on individuals and this was the case
early on he thought so if I go back to
the end of March you know we let some
people some very inexperienced some
people who had just joined us within a
matter of two or three weeks let's say
we had a group of about five people who
kind of came into that can and formula
now of those five people who stayed in
the business and three one now the three
that one you know what what are some of
them were more experienced than the guys
who said well it was mindset and so my
whole philosophy on I suppose business
life per se is if people have got a
growth mindset and they're going to try
then we will find a way to ensure they
can succeed with infinite engine within
recruitment if people have got a fixed
mindset and they're not going to try I'm
not going to try yeah I'm not going to
waste my time or the time of my billing
managers on people who can't be bothered
yes oh you've heard me talk about this
before we talked about will and skill so
if somebody's got the will we can
develop the skill and we can get them
where they need to be if somebody's got
the skill but they haven't got the well
with well we're doomed anyway so to
answer your question I will imagine you
know one to three months from somebody
returning to the business
if within that kind of four to twelve
week period they haven't shown they've
got the will the hostile the drive the
positive mindset to be able to come
achieve in the new world then I'm not
gonna basically kind of put my hand in
my pocket forever and certainly who
isn't giving back so it's we need to see
a response and we need to see positivity
now the interesting thing is young we
don't need to see results straight away
but we need to see the mentality that
yes the world as you said if people are
coming in feeling sorry for themselves
and basically lowering the the mood in
the office and basically bringing
everybody down because it's tough but
it's hard then they become a liability
and you know from August September
onwards people like me are gonna be able
to afford to have huge liabilities set
on their payroll yeah
and then look final thing than John sort
of knowing what you know through the
things in the past that project freedom
what you've been learning and the
conversations you've been having what
would be I guess to people what would be
firstly you advice for recruiters that
are returning to work I think you've
touched on a few things but just to sort
of wrap it up if I'm returning to work
July first or planned to be what would
be your advice for people returning to
work firstly yeah I think to that one I
would basically say that they need to
you know have a conversation with my
manager their building manager and it's
right okay what what do you expect from
me and what do you need from me and what
do I need to produce and perform on a
weekly / monthly basis to ensure that
I'm still in this business Johnson so I
think having that open conversation with
your boss and you know where your sense
of what you don't want is you don't want
surprises where individuals are suddenly
getting kicked out of businesses
and they didn't see it coming so I think
openness and transparency between the
employee and their billing manager is
crucial so I think if the individual
whether it's within village Ames or any
other recruitment company out there you
know they need to know what's expected
so it doesn't come as a shock and it
doesn't come as a surprise
I think most ask great advice great
advice it's like basic equipment isn't
it ask a question you don't hear the
answer to and like you what you want is
exactly that absolutely love that and
the great thing about that anyone
listening is you're in control of that
like you decide if you want to get on
the phone to join your boss or whatever
and say hey obviously really excited to
come back I really want to make sure I
understand what the goal posts are yeah
love that
and then final thing before you finally
actually is when we did our town hall
meetings and we've gone three now we
gave everybody the opportunity to send
through questions prior to you know a
live call with the whole business and we
don't kind of like you know am I gonna
get sacked
how are you John it was lonely like
quite interesting questions and my
answer to the wall on you know how you
gonna get sat and just said that that's
that's I'm not I'm not gonna decide that
you decide whether you're gonna get
sacked because no business owner is
gonna sack an asset who's going to be
good set up good for your business in
the short medium and long term you'll
find another way to do things and what
you do is even when people are making
changes redundancies getting rid of
people you know you don't get rid of
your assets you get rid of your
liabilities so if you've got a part of
stocks you know you don't get rid of the
ones that are rising in value and doing
really really well you don't the you
know the ones that are gonna be a
liability so I say to every recruiter
out there you know if you do what's
expected of you and you show hustle and
drive and the right kind of mentality
and you ask questions and you prepare
sometimes for the difficult
conversations and the difficulty but
you'll be absolutely fine if you come in
half-assed and you know you don't really
care
you expect it to be sat in anyway you
know what you probably gonna get that
yeah and in the final thing before we
finished is just sort of your I guess
forts or advise for recruitment business
owners that are sort of going through
that process of okay what does return to
work that like for my team how should I
structure it how should I roll this out
I guess any sort of anecdotes there or
things that you'd share because maybe
not everyone has access to the the trm
membership or has been listening to what
you've been listening so I guess what
should people be thinking about or yeah
have in mind when thinking about
communicating and getting their their
team employees back into work yeah
couple of things there and you know
what's good is you know through there
like CRM the networks things like that
yeah I've got a lot of mates who run
similar sized companies to myself and I
I pitched their ideas they pinched my
ideas and we share which is great but I
think there's a little bit of older
communication so I think we'll be
leaders and we'll be managers who were
spending more time talking to their
staff and it's more to make them feel
better that all I'm contributing I'm
doing something but what's happening
there is you know that's the less time
that's being spent with individuals
talking to clients and candidates so I
think you know all the communication and
you know 27 zoom calls a week so let me
know what you've done in the last hour I
think is a waste of time I think give
people space and you know I've certainly
done it with our end day I've basically
said look you know you're running the
show you know you basically come to me
if you if you stalk and if you've got
you know a question or you know a
situation or you know that you need some
help with what apartment you know get on
with it
and that's the same with the building
managers you know have you meet in the
morning get on with it and then can't
catch up on you but there's I think
there's all the communication and I
think this is a little bit of too much
you're right you know all the leaders in
the office
talking about it whereas I think you're
better off can uh you know they have any
conversations and then getting out of
the meeting room and get it on with it
so more doing and less talking about it
I think is that is the key and be
careful not to all the communique
because if people are working half days
say it all gets stored you lie and
you're spending 45 minutes in meetings
with them you know you leaving to an
hour three hours try to get to get the
graph done and you're gonna be eating
into that so more time talking to
candidates clients as opposed to
ourselves I think he's gonna be a born
nice look John really enjoyed that
confident a lot of people listening with
some get some really interesting things
in there those stuff on there but anyone
that is listening I think as John said
if you're returning to work I think
really try and use your initiative and
do everything you can to not be have any
horrible surprises which obviously no
one wants to have right so that John
really appreciate you jumping I'm doing
this thanks a lot and keep doing you did
okay it's lovely
see you guys